[Music]
Maintaining a long distance relationship
can be very challenging.
Some people might not have the confidence to go for it
because they worry that it might not work out.
However, if you and your partner are determined to overcome the struggles together,
then your relationship can go stronger than ever.
Are you wondering if you should commit to one?
Here are five signs you are ready for a long distance relationship.
One, you are not afraid of the future.
Being in a long distance relationship
is often scary to couples,
because they are afraid of
what will happen in the future.
Do you think being a part is only temporary?
That nothing will change
because that both of you value commitment?
Are you very sure about each other?
If you answer "yes" to all the above, then it is very likely
that you will get a long distance relationship
with your partner.
Felling confident and secure about what the future has to offer for the both of you,
is what will help the two of you stay closed,
despite the difference in miles or time zones.
Two, you trust each other.
There is no doubt that trust is very important
in a successful relationship.
But sometimes, it can be hard to trust someone due to anxiety, insecurity,
and past of relationships
that ended because of infidelity.
It's important to work these issues out first
before committing to someone again.
Honestly, open communication and understanding
one another are all key factors
that build strong trust between couples.
If you and your partner put time and effort
to fulfill all these needs,
then there's a good chance that the two of you will succeed in a long distance relationship.
Three, you have similar goals.
For a long distance relationship to work out,
both you and your partner have to be certain about
what you want in a relationship,
as well as your goals in life.
Often, relationships fall apart
because two people want different things in life.
For example,
one partner may want to start a family
and live in the suburbs,
while the other dreams of living in the big city,
and desires travelling over having kids.
To make sure you and your partner
are on the same page,
it's important
to have this discussion with them regularly,
to see if your outlook on kids, marriage, jobs,
and location preference
match up as the two of you go together.
Four, you and your partner
are committed to one another.
Do you and your partner
value commitment in a relationship?
Are you attentive in invest
a lot of time and effort into the relationship?
And do you take action
to express your commitment for one another?
Commitment is what separate
serious relationships from casual dating,
and long distance relationships require more of it
because both partners
don't see each other as frequently.
It's important to make sure you and your partner
build a solid relationship first
where compromise is frequently met
before going a long distance ground.
Five, your relationship with your partner is a priority.
Ask yourself honestly,
how important is your partner to you?
The more you value your partner and vice versa,
the more likely your relationship
will survive when it goes long distance.
Here are some questions that can help both of you figure out if your relationship is a top priority.
Do you respect and value
your partner's beliefs and opinions?
Do you remember the details they share with you?
And do you nurture your relationship consistently ?
Remember, a relationship is always a two-way street.
In order for your relationship to survive,
your partner has to be just as invested in it as you.
Do you agree with these points?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Hey everybody, I just wanna give
a personal thank you video for you guys
for always supporting Psy2go
and making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible that it promotes self-awareness
and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make more content for you guys and would love your support
in buying one of these bracelets
from our partner Introvert Palace.
Check out the bracelet, it's pretty cool,
and it even includes gludo.
The link to purchase will all be in the description below and I hope you guys have an amazing day!
Byeee!
Also, don't forget to subscribe from our content from Psy2go and check out our Patreon.
Thanks for watching!